dan Vulcan caught my attention USA Today
national columnist and the night doesn't
pick the headline by the way just an FYI
the writers don't pick their headline
opinion it's time for NCAA to make the
right call tough call and cancel
March Madness and Dan joins us now when
did you start thinking about March
Madness being canceled I started
thinking about it yesterday when the Ivy
League tournament was cancelled we saw a
number of colleges basically go online
only and send kids home talking to
administrators and and frankly just
asking a question which I asked at the
top of the story what happens if a
player test positive for coronavirus
what happens you know even I'm going to
Tampa next week I'm supposed to go cover
that regional in Tampa let's say you
know Florida State plays Arkansas Little
Rock in the first round and Florida
State wins and advances and they're
going to the sweet 16 and then four or
five days later it comes out that one of
the Arkansas Little Rock players test
positive for coronavirus well the way
we're doing this now congressmen who
were in the same room as somebody at a
convention are in quarantine our office
today reporters who were at a conference
convention with people who test positive
for coronavirus they're in quarantine
and and everyone in our office is pretty
much working from home that's what's
happening in this country's so unless
you can answer what happens if a player
test positive which does not seem that
far-fetched to me or coach or game
official or whoever then I don't know if
we really should be having this
tournament at all how much of this and
maybe it's rhetorical is based off money
and the potential for lawsuits well
there's a couple things and and I don't
think any of us are privy to the details
of what is in the CBS contract with the
NC double-a and what kind of insurance
implications there might be if something
like this impacted the NC double-a
tournament but obviously there's there's
financial considerations involved on all
sides frankly you know I think these
conference
tournaments the SEC the ACC Big Ten
pac-12 acting as if nothing is happening
right now I think they're being deeply
irresponsible in holding their
tournaments this weekend with fans in
the stadium that just doesn't seem very
smart I mean look at the SEC Dan
Vanderbilt University is basically shut
down everyone's been sent home they're
holding the SEC Tournament a mile from
from Vanderbilt campus with players from
Vanderbilt involved in the tournament so
given just how little we know about the
virus and how bad it's going to get I
think these decisions need to take a
much wider view here than just money
yeah I'm just trying to figure out what
is the next step because you know when I
saw the Ivy League canceled its
tournament you know that's not a big
revenue a moneymaker there and it's for
schools that were affected by this but
then Yale is going to go to March
Madness so you couldn't have Yale play
in a game in its conference tournament
but the NCAA are you like nobody yell
doesn't have any jurisdiction over this
to say you can't go I'm confused about
this it feels a little hypocritical that
they can't play in that tournament but
they can play in this tournament yeah
and there's other teams at some of these
Ivy League schools who are going and
playing games look I think the rationale
is that there's a certain critical mass
where the number of people in a
gathering you have you know 10 men's and
women's teams and all the staff and all
that in one place that constitutes a
risk and on care to those campuses and
so I sort of understand that versus you
know one team playing one team if that's
the rationale they're going to use but
again I mean like all these NC double-a
tournament sites next week and this is I
think just not what what is being talked
about nearly enough the fans
is one thing and frankly at this point
I'd be a little surprised if they are
going to allow fans in these stadiums at
least for next week but all these
different sites are going to have eight
different teams that's a lot of people
in in one building you know just kind of
given what we know about about the
spread of this thing so III just think
there's not enough attention being paid
to that and and the players I mean again
what happens if a player gets is what
what kind of risk does that present to
the n-c-double-a can we be overly
cautious in a situation like this well
look I think it's a tough thing to
balance overreacting and under-reacting
the fear I have Asians a fear the
calculation that in my mind makes it
make sense to me to delay or cancel
these big sporting events is because we
just don't have testing readily
available in the country right now we
don't know how many people have it we
don't know what the growth rate is so
there's a good chance we could be
looking up in a week and this thing has
spiraled in terms of numbers of
infections numbers of clusters different
cities who knows what what that's going
to look like so there there has to be a
point where if that gets bad enough that
you have to take drastic steps as a
country to control this to slow the
spread of this like Italy right that's
what what's happened in Italy
I'm just so that their society could
function so that their health care
system could deal with with the strain
of a lot of very sick people you know
even if a young healthy person would not
necessarily be be at risk so I mean I
think there's just so many things that I
think it's tough for us to wrap our
minds around because it hasn't hit us
like that yet best guess on what you
think happens to the NCAA tournament
yeah again and this what you what I say
right now could be different in three
hours or 10 hours or 24 hours but I
would say it's going to be difficult for
the NCAA to put this tournament on next
week with fans in the stadium's
what if there's a step beyond that we'll
see I don't know that they have to make
that decision today but they
to make it soon and the tone of their
statement yesterday afternoon certainly
indicated that that big and tough
decisions could be coming dan thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time thank
you Matt Stan Walton USA Today national
columnist saying it's time for the NCAA
to make the right call tough call
cancel March Madness